สวัสดีครับพี่เอ๋สวัสดีค่ะน้องอาร์ตี้
สวัสดีค่ะ
กลับมาเจอกับเราสองคนนะครับในช่อง
compreter ไทยนะครับ
ใช่ครับอยู่ข้างบนนะครับ
เราเจอกันวันอะไรคะครูอาร์ตี้วันนี้วัน
นี้เรามาเจอกันวันเสาร์ครับวันนี้วัน
เสาร์นะคะวันวันที่เท่าไหร่คะวันเสาร์วัน
นี้วันที่ 8 ครับวันที่ 8 เดือนอะไรคะ
เดือนเมษายน
ปีพ.ศอะไรคะพ.ศ
2566 ครับปีค.ศอะไรคะ
[เพลง]
แล้วตอนนี้เวลากี่โมงคะ
วันนี้ก็ข้างหลังครูเอ๋สีม่วง
สีม่วงครับ
โอเคค่ะวันนี้เนี่ย
คลิปสุดท้ายของ
ชุดนี้ไหมอ่าใช่ครับของซีรี่ย์นี้เป็น
ซีรีส์ที่เกี่ยวกับเรื่องราวเกี่ยวกับ
วัดเกี่ยวกับพุทธศาสนานะครับในศาสนาพุทธ
เวลาที่นักเรียนไปวัดนักเรียนจะสังเกต
เห็นเป็นเราเรียกว่าเป็นอะไรครับไม่ใช่คน
เราเรียกว่าเป็นสัตว์ไหม
[เพลง]
ไม่ใช่คนแล้วกันนักเรียนจะเห็นสิ่งนี้
นาคแต่ถ้าเป็นหัวหน้าหน้าก็เรียกว่าพญา
นาค
[เพลง]
ที่เป็นหัวหน้านะครับเราเรียกพญานาค
สีเขียวสีเขียวใช่ครับ
เห็นพญานาคทำไมมีพญานาคอยู่ในวัดนักเรียน
เคยสงสัย
[เพลง]
เกี่ยวกับนาคเกี่ยวกับพญานาคนะครับว่า
ทำไมถึงมีพญานาคทำไมถึงมีนาคอยู่ที่วัด
เป็นคนหรือเปล่านะครับเดี๋ยวเราจะมาคุย
กันนะครับ
ตามตามความเชื่อนะเป็นตำนานหรือที่เขา
เล่ามาเขาเล่ามานานๆแล้วนะครับว่ามีพญา
นาคพญานาค
ตอนนั้นน่ะพญานาค
เกิดความรู้สึกอยากที่จะนับถือศาสนาพุทธ
และอยากจะเข้ามาบวช
แสดงว่าเรื่องนี้เกิดขึ้นในสมัย
พระพุทธเจ้ายังมีชีวิตอยู่ตอนที่พระ
พุทธเจ้ายังมีชีวิตอยู่นะครับแล้วพระ
พุทธเจ้าก็เดินทางแล้วก็สอนสอนคนให้รู้
จัก
การทำความดีการนั่งสมาธิการบำเพ็ญเพียรทำ
สมาธินะครับอ่าศาสนาพุทธสอนพระธรรมใช่
แล้วพญานาคก็ได้ยินได้ยินคำสอนแล้วเกิด
ความความรู้สึกโง่อยากจะบวชบ้างอยากจะบวช
บ้าง
น่าฟังภาษาคนเข้าใจหรอคะใช่น่าฟังภาษาคน
เข้าใจตามตามความเชื่อตามตำนานที่เราฟัง
กันมาเนี่ยเขาเล่ากันมาเนี่ย
ใช่ครับมีพลังสามารถแปลงกายแปลงกายจากที่
เป็นพญานาคแบบนี้นะครับจากที่เป็นตัวพญา
นาคเนี่ยกลายมาเป็นคนได้
สามารถแปลงกายแปลงตัวเนี่ยให้คนอื่นมอง
เห็นพญานาคเป็นคนได้
ปกติก็จะเป็นพญานาคแล้วนาคจะอยู่ใต้น้ำ
อยู่ในน้ำ
แต่ว่าพอขึ้นมาเนี่ยเวลาขึ้นมาถ้าเกิด
เลื้อยเลื้อยไปไหนคนก็จะกลัวใช่ไหม
แล้วก็แปลงกายเรามาแปลงกายให้ตัวเอง
เหมือนคน
[เพลง]
กับครูอาร์ตี้กับครูเอกก็แล้วกันธรรมดา
นักเรียนเห็นแบบนี้ก็สวัสดีค่ะแต่เวลานอน
หลับคุยอาจจะ
เพราะว่าตอนนอนหลับเราไม่มีสติไง
หน้าก็เหมือนกันพอนอนหลับ 100% เนี่ย
หายไปแล้วเนี่ย
ก็
ร่างก็จะเปลี่ยนกลับมาเป็น
หน้าเหมือนเดิมนะ
รูปอื่นๆเดินไปแล้วเห็นเห็นอ้าวทำไมมี
ทำไมมีนาคมานอนอยู่ใน
เขาเรียกว่าในกุฏินะครับเป็นห้องนอนนะ
ครับทำไมมีนาคมานอนอยู่ในกุฏินี้นะครับ
อ่าแล้วหน้าที่นอนหลับอยู่ก็ได้ยินเสียง
เสียงใครพอได้ยินเสียงตัวเองก็ตื่นหน้าก็
ตื่นขึ้นมาแล้วทีนี้มีสติมีสติก็เลยแปลง
ร่างกลับมาเป็นพระเหมือนเดิมกับให้มอง
เห็นเป็นคนเหมือนเดิม
ว่าไม่ใช่คน
นะไม่ใช่คนเป็นหน้าปลอมแปลงกาย
แปลงกายมาเป็นคนแล้วก็เป็นพระอย่างนั้น
ยังจะบวชอยู่ได้ไหมคะทีนี้พอพระรูปอื่น
พระรูปอื่นเห็นแล้วก็รู้แล้วเนี่ยพระองค์
นี้ไม่ใช่คนจริงๆเป็นนาคแรงกายมาก็เลย
กลัวพระอื่นก็จะกลัวก็เลยไปบอกไปบอกพระ
พุทธเจ้า
พระพุทธเจ้าก็เลยบอกว่าบอกกับหน้าว่า
ท่านเป็นหน้าไม่สามารถที่จะบวชได้นะครับ
เพราะพระพุทธเจ้ารู้รู้ว่า
สัตว์หรือ
นาคไม่สามารถที่จะบรรลุบรรลุธรรมได้
ก็เลยก็เลยบอกว่าไม่ให้บวชต้องให้นาคนี้
สึกออกไปแต่นั่นอยากจะเป็นพระมากใช่ไหม
แต่หน้าก็มีความเรียกว่าเลื่อมใสแล้วก็
เชื่อถือเคารพพระพุทธเจ้ามากแล้วก็อยากจะ
บวชแต่พระพุทธเจ้าบอกว่าบวชไม่ได้นะ
ครับแต่ด้วยความที่นาคเนี่ยอยากที่จะช่วย
เหลือนะครับพระพุทธศาสนาหลายๆอย่างนะครับ
ก็เลยขอขอให้คนที่จะมาบวชเนี่ยก่อนที่จะ
มาบวชเนี่ยให้บวชเป็นนาคก่อนก็คือใส่ชุด
สีขาว
พระพุทธเจ้าก็ตอบตกลงนะครับเพราะว่าจริงๆ
แล้วในความหมายของของนาคเนี่ยก็หมายถึง
เป็นหมายถึงว่าเป็นผู้บริสุทธิ์เป็นผู้
ที่พร้อมแล้วที่จะสละเรื่องทางโลก
เรื่องของโลกคือการใช้ชีวิตเป็นคนทั่วไป
ที่จะเข้ามาเป็นเป็นพระเป็นผู้บริสุทธิ์
พระพุทธเจ้าก็เลยตกลงให้เป็นหน้าก่อนแล้ว
ก็ค่อยมาบวชค่อยเป็นพระอีกวันนึงใช่ๆ
เหมือนกับ
เคยอ่านบางเรื่องนะคะครูแอนตี้เขาก็บอก
ว่านาคเนี่ยถ้าปฏิบัติซื้อศีลดีๆวันหนึ่ง
ก็จะมาเกิดใหม่เป็นคน
[เพลง]
งานไม่ตายง่ายๆอ่ะค่ะ
ให้ให้กลับไปกลับไปอยู่ที่ที่บาดาลใน
เมืองบาดาลพญานาคเขาอยู่ใต้น้ำเราเรียก
ใต้น้ำว่าเป็นบาดาลเมืองบาดาลให้กลับไป
รักษา 4 ให้กลับไปบำเพ็ญเพียรแล้ววัน
หนึ่งนะเมื่อนาคก็จะสามารถเกิดมาเป็นคน
เพราะเกิดมาเป็นคนก็จะสามารถบวชได้นะครับ
[เพลง]
ใช่ครับ
แต่จริงๆแล้วเนี่ยพญานาคยังมีประวัติ
อย่างอื่นอีกนะครูอาร์ตี้แต่วันนี้เราเรา
เล่าเรื่องที่เกี่ยวกับว่าทำไมนักเรียนไป
วัดเห็นนาคอยู่ในวัดเพราะอะไรทำไมเวลาคน
จะบวชคนจะบวชพระทำไมต้องปวดหน้าก่อนใส่
ชุดขาวนี่เป็นที่มาที่ไปที่จะมาเล่า
เรื่องนี้บางทีก็อาจจะเห็นพระพุทธรูปที่
มีนาคอยู่
มีเยอะๆแต่หน้าแดง
แล้วก็ศรัทธาพระพุทธเจ้ามาก
ก็มีบางโอกาสที่ที่หน้าก็จะคอยช่วยเหลือ
พระพุทธเจ้าในการเผยแพร่ศาสนาในการปกป้อง
แล้วก็ดูแลพระพุทธเจ้าตามความสามารถทำได้
ด้วยความที่น่าเกี่ยวข้องกับในประวัติ
พุทธประวัติก็เลยชี้วัดไทยก็เลยจะมี
พญานาคใช่ก็จะมีวัดแต่ละวัดก็จะเอามีรูป
ของพญานาคในการที่จะช่วยเหลือการเผยแพร่
ศาสนาการต่อสู้กับมารต่างๆหรือช่วยพระ
พุทธเจ้าในรูปแบบต่างๆอยู่ที่ในวัดหรือ
หน้าโบสถ์นะครับเป็นภาพอยู่ในโบสถ์ก็มี
เหมือนกันนะครับ
บันไดไหมคะอันนี้เป็นบันไดเป็นบันไดหน้า
นะครับ
หรือบางครั้งนี่นักเรียนก็จะเห็นภาพแบบ
นี้เป็นภาพพญานาคนะครับอยู่ในโบสถ์
ในปากพญานาคมีอะไรในปากพญานาคอันนี้ก็
เป็นลูกแก้วครับเพราะว่าคนเราเชื่อว่าพญา
นาคเนี่ยมีอายุเยอะนะครับแล้วก็
บำเพ็ญเพียรรักษาศีลเยอะแล้วก็จะมีมี
สมบัติมีสมบัติเยอะด้วยแล้วก็มีลูกแก้ว
ของพญานาคแก้วก็เป็นเป็นสมบัติอย่างหนึ่ง
นะครับของลูกแก้วนี่ทำให้พญานาคแปลงกาย
ได้ใช่ไหม
ล่ะครับ
ครูเอ๋ก็ไม่รู้นะคะนักเรียนครูเอ๋ก็ดู
ซีรีย์แล้วเขาบอกอ๋อก็เป็นตำนานแต่ละพื้น
ที่
บางที่ก็มีตำนานเกี่ยวกับลูกแก้วของพญา
นาคเหมือนกัน
[เพลง]
สีเขียวนะครับ
เป็นสีเขียวนะ
หรือคู่เอกมองเป็นสีทอง
นะคะจริงๆพญานาคมีหลายสีใช่ไหม
อ่าได้ยินว่าได้ยินนะคะว่ามีสีทอง
เขียวสีดำสีขาว
ไม่แน่ใจแบบนี้นี่ควรที่มีรูปนะครับเป็น
พญานาคที่ตามความเชื่อนะครับว่าเหมือนกับ
คนครับคนก็มีแต่ละเชื้อชาติแต่ละประเทศก็
มีสีที่แตกต่างกันไปพญานาคก็มีเหมือนกัน
มีหลายๆอยู่ในหลายๆพื้นที่ก็มีสีแตกต่าง
กันไปนะครับมี 4 สีที่เราที่เราเคยได้ยิน
กันมานะครับ
สีทองสีดำสีขาวแล้วก็สีเขียวเวลานักเรียน
ไปเห็นที่วัดทำไมที่วัดนี้นาคเป็นสีเขียว
ทำไมที่วัดนี้เป็นสีทองเป็นสีต่างๆก็จะมี
ทั้งหมด 4 สีที่เราจะเห็นกันอยู่ก็มาจาก 4
ครอบครัวนะคะนักเรียน
ครอบครัวหนึ่งก็จะมีสีหนึ่ง
ของการบวชก่อนที่จะบวชเนี่ยต้องบวชเป็น
หน้าก่อน
การบวชเป็นหน้าก็คือเอ่อในวันที่เราบวช
เนี่ยก็จะมีการโกนผมใช่ไหม
พระโกนหรือว่าให้พ่อให้แม่หรือให้เป็น
ญาติผู้ใหญ่โกนผมก็ได้นะครับในวันที่เรา
บวชแต่ก็ต้องมีพระลงโกนด้วย
1 ครั้งก็ได้ค่ะ
เพราะอย่างพี่ชายเอ๋ก็พระท่านก็จะตัดให้
ครั้งหนึ่งนะครับครั้งหนึ่งแล้วที่เหลือ
ก็กลับมาบ้านพ่อแม่ตัดๆๆแล้วก็ช่างมีช่าง
ช่างตัดผมมาโกน
ใช่ครับเป็นคนที่มีความชำนาญในการโกนผมนะ
เพราะว่าถ้าโกนไม่ดีเนี่ยจะเป็นแผลนะจะ
เป็นแผลเจ็บ
แล้วก็ก็คือทำการบวชนาคก่อน 1 วันวันนี้
ใช่
จะบวชเป็นพระในวันพรุ่งนี้นะครับ
ขวัญนาค
นี้
ทำยังไง
ทำขวัญนาคก็ก็จะเป็นพิธีหรือจะมีมีเขา
เรียกว่าเป็นเป็นผู้นำในการทำขวัญเขาก็จะ
มากล่าวคำต่างๆเกี่ยวกับพระคุณของพ่อแม่
มีพระคุณกับคนที่บวชนะครับมีพระคุณกับเรา
ยังไงมีพระคุณเลี้ยงดูเรามาจนเราเติบโต
ขึ้นมาจนถึงอายุ 20 พ่อแม่ให้หาอาหารให้
กินหาโรงเรียนหาความวิชาความรู้ต่างๆให้
เราได้ศึกษาเล่าเรียนและจนเขาก็จะพูดตั้ง
แต่อะไรนะคุณแม่ท้องเนาะใช่ๆคือจริงๆพูด
ถึงคุณพ่อคุณแม่ดีกับเราใช่ไหมคะ
[เพลง]
ดีกับเรามากๆคุณพ่อทำงานมากๆเอาเงินให้
คุณแม่คุณแม่เนี่ยก็ท้องใช่ไหมส่วนใหญ่จะ
พูดถึงคุณแม่มากๆคุณแม่ท้อง 9 เดือน
9 เดือนเนี่ยลูกอยู่ในเนี้ยเวลาคุณแม่
อยากจะกินอันนี้อ้าวไม่ดีกับลูกไม่กินก็
ไม่กินต้องอดทนด้วยนะครับอยากกินสิ่งอ่า
ที่ตัวเองอยากกินก็ไม่ได้อ่าต้องกินสิ่ง
ที่ดีที่ดีกับลูกที่อยู่ในท้อง
อดทนก็นอนลำบาก
คือเขาเรียกว่าหมอทำขวัญใช่ไหมคะหมอคำ
ขวัญนาคเขาก็จะ
เขาก็จะพูดแต่จริงๆก็ไม่เรียกเขาเรียก
อะไรนะ
เขาเรียกถ้าเป็นภาษาไทยนะศัพท์คนไทยก็
เรียกว่าแหล่ใช่ไหม
แต่ก็พูดให้ธรรมดามีจังหวะมีจังหวะเป็น
เพลงแหล่ทำขวัญนะแต่เนื้อกว่าสิ่งที่พูด
ออกมาก็บอกเกี่ยวกับคุณของคุณแม่ที่ดีกับ
เราดีกับนาคยังไงนะครับ
บางคนนะฟังไปก็ซึ้งนะครับ
คิดถึงบุญคุณของคุณพ่อคุณแม่นะครับ
[เพลง]
แล้วพอทำขวัญนาคเสร็จวันพรุ่งนี้วันพรุ่ง
นี้ก็ไปบวชนะครับ
ก็มาบวก
เพราะเวลาเราบวชเนี่ยเราก็ต้องไปบวชที่
วัดนะครับ
แต่ในรูปนี้ค่ะ
[เพลง]
น่าจะเป็นธูปเป็นเทียนนะครับอ่าเป็น
อุปกรณ์ที่ใช้ในการเอ่อบวชนะครับแล้วก็
ข้างหลังมีมีฉากใช่ไหมคือเป็นร่มเย็นใช่
ครับเป็นร่มใหญ่ๆเราบางคนก็เรียกว่าฉัตร
นะครับ
[เพลง]
คือบังแดดครับเพราะว่าประเทศไทยเนี่ยแดด
ร้อน
มากต้องมีต้องมีต้องมีฉัตรมีร่มด้วยเพราะ
ว่านาคไม่มีผมแล้วถ้าถูกแดดจริงๆจะร้อน
มากครับแล้วก็จะมีชุดที่เป็นชุดพระเนี่ย
คุณแม่ถือ
มีหมอนมีเอ่อเขาเรียกว่าถ้าเป็นศัพท์ทาง
ทางของพระก็อรรถบริขารคือของใช้ของพระอ่า
มีอะไรบ้างนะครับมีอ่ามีหมอนมีผ้าผ้า
ไตร่ภาคไตรจีวรส
ต่างๆอ่าสังคตินะครับ
ก็จะมีเอ่อถือมาพร้อมๆกันเพราะว่าเวลาบวช
เราต้องใช้นะครับอ่าพอเป็นพระต้องใช้เงิน
เดือนรอบโบสถ์นักเรียนจะเห็นโบสถ์นะคะ
เป็นแบบนี้นี่คือโบสถ์ใช่ครับ
อ่า
เดินรอบโบสถ์ 3 รอบครับ
เหมือนตอนที่เราเวียนเทียนนะแล้วก็อ่า
เป็นการเคารพเอ่อพระพุทธบูชาก็คือพระพุทธ
พระธรรมพระสงฆ์สามย่าน 3 รอบนะครับอ่า
เสร็จแล้วตอนที่เข้าไปบวชเนี่ยมีคำถามอีก
เพราะว่าตั้งแต่ตั้งแต่ตอนที่พระพุทธเจ้า
บอกว่าคนที่จะบรรลุธรรมได้ต้องเป็นคนเท่า
นั้นนะครับมีคำถามตอนที่พระอุปัชฌาย์จะ
บวชให้พระอุปัชฌาย์ก็จะถามคุณเป็นคนหรือ
เปล่า
ตอนนั้นคือใส่ชุดสีอะไร
ชุดเปลี่ยนชุดหรือยังเปลี่ยนชุดแล้ว
เปลี่ยนชุดแล้วแล้วก็จะมายืนอยู่ข้างหน้า
พระอุปัชฌาย์
ประตูพระอุปัชฌาย์เขาจะถามคุณเป็นมนุษย์
หรือเปล่ามนุษย์ถ้าเป็นภาษาบาลีที่เขาใช้
ถามกัน
ส่วนคนที่บวชใหม่ก็จะต้องตอบว่า
อามะภันเตเป็นครับเป็นคนครับ
ให้บวชไม่ได้นะเพราะว่าไม่ใช่คน
โอเคแล้วก็ยังมีเอ่อเรื่องเรื่องเล่า
เกี่ยวกับเอ่อนาคหรือพญานาคอยู่อีกในความ
เชื่อของคนไทยนะครับอ่า
ครับคนไทยหลายคนนะคะนักเรียนก็เขาเรียก
ว่านับถือเนอะ
พญานาคนะคะ
ไม่ใช่นาคที่เป็นคนที่ครูอาร์ตี้เอามาให้
ดูนะคะอ่าไม่ใช่ครับอันนี้ก็อันนี้ก็เป็น
พระก็จบไปเป็นพระแต่ความเชื่อถือเกี่ยว
กับความความศักดิ์สิทธิ์ความมีฤทธิ์มี
อำนาจมีพลังของพญานาคเนี่ยคนไทยก็นับถือ
ก็เชื่อถือเหมือนกัน
แล้วก็มันจะมีมันจะมีงานมีงานเป็นงาน
ประจำปีนะครับเรื่องที่มีพญานาคบั้งไฟพญา
นาค
[เพลง]
เหมือนกันนะครับมีที่ไหนคะบั้งไฟพญานาค
บั้งไฟพญานาคจะมีทางภาคอีสานครับเป็น
จังหวัดที่ติดกับแม่น้ำโขงเพราะว่าพญา
นาคเนี่ยอาศัยอยู่ในแม่น้ำใช่ไหมแล้วทาง
ภาคอีสานก็จะมีแม่น้ำใหญ่อยู่นะครับแม่
น้ำโขงนะครับเนี่ยเดี๋ยวบั้งไฟคืออะไรดู
แผนที่ก่อนอ่าแม่น้ำโขงนะครับ
ไปอยู่บริเวณนี้ครับระหว่างประเทศไทยตรง
นี้นะครับติดกับประเทศลาวตรงนี้จะมีสิ้น
สีเขียวๆนะครับ
จะมีแม่น้ำอยู่เราเรียกว่าแม่น้ำโขงก็จะ
มีประเพณีของการไปดูไปดูบั้งไฟพญานาคใน
ทุกๆปีนะครับที่หนองคายไหมคะ
หนองคายบึงกาฬนะครับเมื่อก่อนเมื่อก่อน
บึงกาฬก็เป็นจังหวัดหนึ่งของหนองคาย
เหมือนกัน
แต่ตอนนี้แยกกันแล้วแยกเป็นจังหวัด
หนองคายกับจังหวัดบึงกาฬนะครับ
แต่ก็ยังมีประเพณีในการไปดูบั้งไฟพญานาค
กันที่ที่บึงกาฬแล้วก็ที่หนองคายนะครับ
ตัวบั้งไฟพญานาคคืออะไร
บั้งไฟพญานาคที่ไปดูเนี่ยโคโยตี้ยังไม่
เคยไปดูนะเขาบอกว่ามันจะเป็นลูกไฟกลมๆมี
รูปไหมคะมีรูปนะครับเดี๋ยวนะผมอยู่นะตรง
นี้ตรงนี้มีรูปที่เขาแสดงขึ้นมานะครับ
แต่คนที่ไปดูจริงๆเนี่ยเขาก็มีคนที่เคย
เห็นนะครับ
ในแต่ละปีก็จะมีบั้งไฟพญานาคคนไทยหลายๆคน
ที่มีความเชื่อแล้วก็ต้องการที่จะเห็นนะ
ครับก็ไปดูอ่าบั้งไฟพญานาค
ใช่ๆ
คิดว่าเราคิดว่าพญานาคอ่ะใครบั้งไฟจากใน
น้ำถ่ายรูปไฟออกจากในน้ำแล้วก็ลอยขึ้นมา
นะครับ
เห็นแว๊บๆ
รูปนี้ใช่ไหมครับนี่ก็เป็นคนที่ไปรอดูพญา
นาคตอนนี้ยังยังไม่มีนะเพราะว่าดวง
อาทิตย์ยังเป็นตอนกลางวันอยู่ต้องรอตอน
ก่อนนักเรียนมืดๆแล้วเนี่ยนะพอกลางคืน
ปั๊บเนี่ยนักเรียนเห็นข้างหลังเนี่ยเป็น
แม่น้ำใช่ไหมคะแม่น้ำโขงเนี่ยเพราะมืด
ปั๊บเนี่ยจะมีตู้ไฟแต่ลูกไฟเขาบอกเป็นอาจ
จะมีลูกไฟกลมๆลอยขึ้นมา
ลอยขึ้นมาจากจากแม่น้ำนี้ครับ
ก็เรียกว่าบั้งไฟพญานาคคนไทยก็เชื่อว่า
พญานาคปล่อย
ใช่ไหมปล่อยบ้างไปออกมาหรือพ่น
[เพลง]
ออกมาคือปล่อยออกมาจากปากนั่นเองนะครับ
ปล่อยเป็นรูปไฟกลมๆลอยขึ้นมาลอยขึ้นมา
อันนี้เป็นอ่าสิ่งที่พญานาคทำได้ใช่ไหมคะ
อืม
ก็เอ่อเราเชื่อว่านะคนไทยบางคนนะครับก็
ที่ที่ไปดูพญานาคไปดูบั้งไฟพญานาคก็เชื่อ
ว่าวันนั้นน่ะเป็นวันที่พญานาคเนี่ยเอ่อ
ทำความเคารพแล้วก็เอ่อเฉลิมฉลองยินดีกับ
การกลับมาของพระพุทธเจ้า
เพราะว่าบั้งไฟพญานาคจะมีวันออกพรรษาครับ
วันออกพรรษาคือวันที่
พระพุทธเจ้า
วันที่พระพุทธเจ้าเนี่ยเสด็จกลับมาจาก
สวรรค์
แล้วพญานาคก็ดีใจที่พระพุทธเจ้ากลับมา
แล้วนะครับกลับมาที่โลกมนุษย์แล้วพญานาค
ก็เลยดีใจออกมาฉลองกันด้วยการจุดพลุของ
พญานาคกับคนไทยเราเรียกว่าเป็นบั้งไฟพญา
นาคเป็นวันนั้นนะครับเดือนตุลาคมนะคะนัก
เรียนใช่ครับเดือนตุลาคมเป็นวันออกพรรษา
ถ้าเป็นเดือนไทยเนี่ยจะเป็นเอ่อ 5 ค่ำใช่
ไหม
ถ้าค่ำเดือน 11 อ่ะคือเดือนเดือนที่ 10
นักเรียนเดือนที่ 10 หรือเดือนที่ 10 ใน
ใช่ไหมคะสำหรับทั้งหมด 8 เดือนไทยอะไร
เขียนชื่อเดือนที่ 10 ให้นักเรียนดูหน่อย
ได้ไหมคะอ่าเดือน 10 ถ้าเอ่อเดี๋ยวนะ
ถ้าเดือน 10 ของสากลนะทั่วไปนะเหมือนที่
ประเทศนักเรียนที่ประเทศต่างๆเนี่ยจะเป็น
เดือนนี้ใช่
คนไทยบอก 11
เดือนของประเทศไทยเดือนของคนไทยนะจะเป็น
เดือน 11
แต่ของไทย 11
[เสียงหัวเราะ]
ใช่เดือนไทยจะเป็นเดือน 10 เพราะว่าเดือน
ของไทยเราเรานับตามพระจันทร์ใช่ไหมครับ
ก็อาจจะมีแตกต่างกันนิดหน่อยนิดหน่อยนะ
ครับ
ก็คนก็จะไปรอดูบั้งไฟกันเต็มเลยนะคะนัก
เรียน
เรื่องพญานาคเนี่ยสมัยก่อนนะคะนักเรียนก็
จะมีมากๆทางอีสานทางภาคเหนือ
แต่ปัจจุบันนี้เรื่องของพญานาคคนไทยทั้ง
ประเทศเลยวัดไทยหลายๆวัดนะคะหลายๆวัดต้อง
บอกนะคะ
ก็จะมีการมีรูปปั้นเกี่ยวกับพญานาค
พญานาคเพิ่มขึ้นเยอะเลยเนี่ยเดี๋ยวครูเอ๋
มีให้ดูนิดนึง
ไม่ได้ไปนะ
เพื่อที่จะเห็นบ่อยปกติเวลาไปวัดก็จะเห็น
พญานาคเยอะๆนะครับตามบันไดอะไรอย่างนี้
โอ้อันนี้สวยเลยครับได้มีลูกแก้วด้วย
พญานาค 2 ตัวนะครับลูกแก้วอยู่ตรงกลาง
แล้วก็อันนี้ก็น่าจะเป็นความเชื่อนะคะว่า
ถ้าไปแล้วก็ไปจับจับลูกแก้ว
[เพลง]
ด้วยครับอ่าต้องช่วยกันต้องช่วยกันไม่ใช่
ไปจับลูกแก้วขอลอตเตอรี่แต่ว่าไม่ทำงาน
อันนี้ก็ไม่ได้
แต่ครูเอกก็ไม่ทราบนะคะว่าเขาขออะไรคนนี้
ไม่บอกไม่บอกกลัวตี้เวลากลัวตี้ไปขอกลัว
ตี้ก็ไม่บอกใคร
ได้จริงไหม
ครูเอกไม่ทราบบางคนเขาบอกว่าได้เหมือนกับ
ว่าถ้าคิด
เปิดร้านอาหารนะคะแล้วก็พอไปขอปั๊บก็
อยู่ๆก็มีเงินแล้วก็เปิดร้านอาหารได้นะคะ
ครูอาร์ตี้อยากได้ยอด Subscribe อีกสัก
500 ก็ไปขอไปขอพญานาคใช่ไหม
ขออย่างเดียวไม่ได้นะ
มีโคโยตี้ก็มีรูปนึงรูปนี้เนี่ยอยู่ใน
จังหวัดชลบุรีนะครับ
[เพลง]
นี่ครับถ้ำรอดมหาจักรพรรดินะครับอยู่
ชลบุรี
เดี๋ยวนี้มีการปั้นรูปพญานาคเยอะมาก
ซึ่งสมัยก่อนตอนครูเอ๋เด็กๆไม่มีนะ
มีนิดหน่อยนะคะมีที่โบสถ์และที่บันไดเท่า
นั้นนะคะ
ที่นี่เขาให้คนไปไหว้ใช่ไหมคะใช่ให้คน
เข้าไปไหว้ด้วยเป็นถ้ำเป็นสถานที่ท่อง
เที่ยวด้วยคนไปได้ไปเที่ยวทะเลไปชลบุรี
ใช่ไหมไปเที่ยวทะเลไปพัทยาแล้วก็แวะแวะ
ไหว้พญานาคที่นี่
ตามความเชื่อนะคะนักเรียนถ้าคุณรู้สึกว่า
มีความเชื่ออยากจะไหว้พญานาคก็ไปไหว้แต่
ว่าถ้าคุณไม่แน่ใจอยากจะดูเท่านั้นก็ไป
แล้วก็ดูได้ไปถ่ายรูปสวยๆก็ได้ครับมีอีก
ที่นึงมีอีกที่นึงที่เป็นที่ที่คนไทยนิยม
ไปเหมือนกันครับเป็นถ้ำเหมือนกันแต่ว่า
ที่นี่เกิดจากธรรมชาติครับไม่ใช่คนปั้น
ไม่ใช่คนทำขึ้นมาไม่ใช่คนปั้นขึ้นมาคนแถว
นั้นก็เลยคิดว่าอ๋อที่นี่อาจจะเป็นถ้ำของ
พญานาคจริงๆก็ได้นะครับอ่าที่นี่ครับนี่
คือพญานาคใช่ไหมอันนี้เป็นเป็นก้อนหินที่
อยู่ในถ้ำนะครับแล้วดูคล้ายๆคล้ายๆเกร็ด
พญานาคไหม
อ่าเหมือนพญานาคกำลังนอน
เวลาคนไปที่นี่ก็จะไปไหว้ตรงเนี้ยค่ะใช่
ครับ
เพราะว่าเกิดจากธรรมชาตินะ
อ่า
มีตัวด้วยครับมีหลายๆที่เลยมีลำตัวมีเอ่อ
หัวต่างๆนะครับอันนี้ก็เป็นพื้นทางเดิน
ซึ่งเหมือนเหมือนกับเกล็ดพญานาคแบบนี้ใช่
ๆเหมือนกับเกล็ดพญานาคที่ข้างหลังคู่เอก
นะ
แล้วก็ใหญ่มากนะคะนักเรียน
ภูเขาเลยค่ะ
เป็นเป็นถ้ำแต่เป็นภูเขาเลยค่ะใช่ครับ
เป็นถ้ำอยู่บนภูเขา
ตรงนี้เขาก็เชื่อว่าเหมือนกับพญานาคตาย
แล้วก็กลายเป็นก้อนหิน
เป็นความเชื่อนะครับหรือถ้าใครต้องการที่
จะไปท่องเที่ยวว่าเป็นสถานที่ธรรมชาติก็
ได้เหมือนกันครับสามารถไปท่องเที่ยวได้นะ
ครับ
โอเคอ้าวอันนี้เราก็
ได้คุยกันนะครับ
ว่าพญานาคเกี่ยวกันยังไงกับเวลานักเรียน
ไปวัดเห็นพญานาคทีนี้นักเรียนก็จะเข้าใจ
แล้วนะครับว่าเอ่อพญานาคหรือนาคเนี่ย
เกี่ยวกับศาสนาพุทธยังไงบ้างนะครับใช่
แล้วก็คนไทยเชื้อยังไงนะคะคือจริงๆเกี่ยว
กับศาสนาพุทธแต่บางคนก็เชื่อว่าอ่าไปไหว้
แล้วโชคดีหรือไปจับลูกแก้วแล้วโชคดีหรือ
มีพญานาคเล็กๆที่บ้านเราโชคดีก็แล้วแต่
ความเชื่อนะคะ
อื้อหือ
โอเคได้วันนี้เราก็หมดเวลาแล้วครับสำหรับ
เรื่องพญานาคนะครับแล้วเดี๋ยว
เรากลับมาเจอกันใหม่คราวหน้านะครับวันนี้
เราสองคนต้องลาไปก่อนแล้วครับอ้อถ้าใคร
ใครที่ดูคลิปมาถึงตอนนี้แล้วยังไม่ได้กด
Subscribe นะฝากกด Subscribe ให้ด้วยนะ
ครับในช่องของไทย
กด Subscribe แล้วเนี่ยกดไลค์กดไลค์ด้วย
นะ
ครับหรือถ้ามีคำถามก็สามารถคีย์ไว้ในช่อง
comment แล้วก็ถามพวกเราได้ว่าอยากจะรู้
เรื่องอะไรหรืออยากมีคำที่สงสัยนะครับ
อะไรก็ทำได้นะครับ
โอเควันนี้เราสองคนต้องลาไปก่อนแล้วครับ
กลับมาเจอกันใหม่ครับสวัสดีครับพี่เอ๋
สวัสดีค่ะ
[เพลง]